[موسيقى]
الفن من اهم المجالات اللي بتحتاج لاداره
فعاله لضمان استمراريتها قد ما كان العمل
الفني جميل وابداعي لازم يكون مدار بشكل
صح لنقدر نحقق اهدافه وبالمقابل وجود الفن
بالاداره بيكسر الروتين والنمطيه اللي
ممكن تصير المتحدث الثاني اللي معنا قدر
يدمج بين هالمفهومه كونه مايسترو ومدير
عام الهيئه العامه لدار الاسد للثقافه
والفنون وترك بصمته الخاصه بمجال الاداره
بمكان مليء بانجازات مشرفه
كل عمل فني بحاجه لاداره وكل اداره بحاجه
الى فن موضوع خطاب المايسترو اندريه
معلولي
[تصفيق]
مرحبا جميعا
لا شك
نحن كفنانين متعودين دائما نوقف على
المسارح
ولكن دائما هناك رهبه الوقوف على المسرح
في كل مره نقف فيها على المسرح
وخاصه
بعد قامات كبيره كانت تسبقني على هذا
المسرح فلي الشرف ان اكون بمقامهم
والشكر دائما
للشباب
المعطى
المتوهج دائما في الابداع الذي هو ايضا فن
باللحظه الاولى اللي طلب مني انه شارك
بهذا الحدث
حاولت اتهرب
لانه بعتبر انه لسه خبرتي
بحاجه لصقل كثير كبير لحتى اقدر اطرحها
الحقيقه فكرت بشو بدي احكي لقيت موضوع كان
عم يشغلني انا شخصيا خلال الفتره الماضيه
فنان عزفت درست الموسيقى وحبيت الموسيقى
وكان في الي دائما مثل اعلى بحياتي كان هو
الاستاذ صلح الوادي رحمه الله اللي علمنا
قيمه الوقت اولا وقيمه الفن
وكنت واذا حبيت الاداره فحبيت الاداره من
خلاله
طبعا كاي شخص عملت في الموسيقى ولم امتهن
الموسيقى حتى الان
لانه اعتبر ان الفن هو دائما يجب ان يكون
هوايه وليس عمل لانه يفقد قدسيته
لذلك لما توجهت الى العمل الاداري وكنت
عميدا سابقا للمعهد العالي للموسيقى
وانتقلت الى
او ما فيني اقول انتقلت حتى تكون وصف دقيق
شرفني القدر بان اكون مديرا عاما لصرح
ثقافيا كبير
نفتخر في سوريا باننا
لدينا دار الاسد الثقافي والفنون هذا
الصرح الذي نتباهى فيه على المستوى العربي
والعالمي
صرت فكر انه الفن والاداره هل هنن كلمتين
لمعنى واحد
واسقط هذه التجارب كلها لحتى وصلت
لجمله ان لكل عمل فني حتى يعني يكون ناجحا
يجب ان يكون له اداره
وكل اداره يجب ان يكون لها فن
فن الاداره
واداره الفن
هذا هذا
الجمله اللي فعلا استفزتني لحتى بكل عمل
بقوم فيه حاول استخرج هذه او المعنى
الحقيقي لهذه الجمله
الاداره والفن لاحظت انه هن معنا واحد
قديش نحن بننجح باداره اعمالنا هدفا
نملكه بالفطره ولا نتعلمه
الفن اليوم بيجي بموهبه يثقل عبر الدراسه
الاداره خبره وكاريزما وايضا موهبه تكون
موجوده عند الشخص
ولان الوقت قصير حاولت انه حط بعض الجمل
يلي ممكن تعمل محفز فكري عند الانسان حتى
يقدر يفكر تماما بالربط بهذا الموضوع
واسقاطه ليس فقط على الفن ولكن على كل
الاختصاصات بالحياه
لانه انا بقول دائما
الحياه بالمجمل هي فن واداره
فعندما نقول ان الاداره هي فن اتخاذ
القرار
والاداره هي فن التفكير السريع
هناك ايضا مقوله ان الاختلاف ادب
والتعبير عنه فن
الوقت هو اندر الموارد
اذا لم نتمكن من ادارته فلن نتمكن من
اداره اي شيء اخر
كل شخص يعرف كيف يتوجب على الاخرين اداره
حياتهم
لكن لا احد يعرف عن حياته هو
فدائما كنت لاحظ دائما انه في اشخاص بتعطي
ملاحظات
لاداره معينه او لمدير
وبالوقت لما بصير في هذا التغيير وبيصير
هو بهذا المكان ما بياخد بالملاحظات اللي
هو اعطاها فهون كمان
فن من الفنون اللي لازم نقدر نعرف كيف انا
كفنان على خشبه المسرح دير هذا العمل
بالمكتب لما بدي يكون عندي اداره وعندي
مؤسسه لازم ديرها فهناك ايضا نفس العمليه
لما بكون في اوركسترا وفي عده الات
موسيقيه هالالات الموسيقيه كلياتها على
المسرح
بتعزف بانغام مختلفه كل اله تقدم لحن
مختلف عن الاخر حتى المتلقي يستمع الى لحن
واحد يستمتع به
نفس الشيء بالاداره عندما نلاحظ ان هناك
عده اقسام كل قسم يعمل باختصاص ولكن
يصدر عن هذه المؤسسه او عن هذه الهيئه
عملا مميزا واحدا فالنجاح هذا العمل مرتبط
بفن ربط هذه الادارات الصغيره ضمن الاداره
الكبيره
الفن هو الاسلوب هو الاسلوب هو الانسان
لكل انسان اسلوبه في الفن وفي الاداره
عندما نقدم سيمفونيه من السيمفونيات
ولناخذ مثالا على ذلك
سنفونيه الخامسه القدر
كل انسان يفهم
هذه هذا العمل بشكل مختلف عن الاخر لانه
يلامس لديه جزئيه مختلفه عن عن شخص اخر
نقدم هذا العمل خلال العام
باكثر من مره وفي كل مره نلاحظ ان هناك
اختلاف
في طريقه فهم العمل
حتى يقال في انه القائد الاوركسترا الشهير
كريان قدمه السيمفونيه الخامسه بعده مرات
ويقال ان افضلها في سنه كذا اذا هناك فهم
مختلف دائما لي وطريقه ورؤيه
وعمليه اداره هذا العمل الفني
نعكس هذا الموضوع نلاحظ ان الاداره ايضا
هي بحاجه الى فكر وقد يكون الفكر مختلف
بين شخص واخر لاداره ولكن هناك رؤيه يجب
ان يكون هناك دائما رؤيه في العمل الفني
وفي الاداره في كل الامثله التي اطرحها
لاحظت انه بالاخير وصل لنتيجه مهمه جدا
الفن العظيم هو الفن السهل للناس
والصعب للفنان
وهو ما نستطيع او استطيع ان يلامسه في
الاداره انه قد يكون سهل لكل الناس
الاي قرار ولكن صعب على الاداره عندما
تتخذ القرار
لملاحظه بالاخير
بانه واللي انا قدرت اكتشفه من خلال
تجربتي الصغيره جدا جدا جدا
انه الاداره والفن هنن كلمتين لمعنى واحد
بهذه الجمل البسيطه
والوقت الصغير حاولت انه اعطي شيء من
وجداني من روحي لحتى اكون صادق تماما في
هذا الكلام
والتجربه اللي مرقت فيها ان كانت تجربتي
في الفن والتجربه في الاداره على امل انه
يكون وفقت
باظهار هذه التجربه والمعنى لهذا الحدث
الكبير ان يكون الفن والاداره هما كلمتين
لمعنى واحد شكرا لالكم شكرا لاصاحه